it's been quite a while since the last
episode and I want to just shortly
mention why that is even if I don't
usually like talking about my life I
think this video series exists not just
on YouTube since it's related to a whole
different project so basically after the
last video I went to LA had to do some
school stuff when I came back and
finally I was sick for about a week so I
couldn't record this commentary even
though I more or less have the footage
lying around already and that's also why
my voice is still perhaps a little bit
weird if you ever noticed that my voice
sounds like I have a cold well that's
because I do in any case one one thing
that I should really mention is that in
the meantime the live stream which this
map was built for has already been held
and honestly I've had the pleasure of
watching that at 6:00 in the morning
from a hostel in Hollywood which works
out either way and it was really cool to
see even if I was just catching into the
stream at a later stage because earlier
would have just been way too much in the
middle of the night for me that many
people were able to just reply to all my
questions and everything I was chatting
about in English as well even though the
stream itself is focused on Norwegian
language since it's for Norwegian people
and done and done by Norwegian students
and Norwegian streamer as well but it
was still really fun to see everything
happen and really cool to see all the
students get this map and kind of mess
with it try and think of ways to change
the map for instance really cool to see
the the landscape architect's actually
work with the landscape try and create a
park out of what was in the past some
horrible area somewhere in okay so it
was really cool to see all of that stuff
in any case I maybe digressing a little
bit there the the most important point
of this whole story is that more or less
the points to this whole build is in the
past already and even though I recorded
this episode which you're looking at a
few weeks in the past I have to say that
I am actually continuing this series a
little bit
even though this the whole point has
already been done you know the the map
was made for the live stream and the
live stream has been held already but
the thing is I set out to make the
entirety of Oslo before that live stream
and I didn't actually make it and
there's huge areas of these suburbs and
outer mountains of Oslo which are not
built yet but also I got so many
comments on YouTube from people telling
me to continue this series so here we
are I think it'll be nice to at least
bring this to a nice closure and add at
least a few more episodes just to make
sure that I get a recreation of Oslo
which is as close as I can get without
spending too much time on it because to
be very honest I think for one I don't
have that much time to put into this
there's some other stuff that I have to
do there's some school stuff that I have
to do and then there's just life
continues outside of that as well but
also I just think that doing a city like
this completely in a huge level of
detail is almost impossible and usually
a little bit too ambitious I think a
point in case there is crumbs maki's
rotterdam series which no offense to
chromakey as amazing as that series is
and it is actually one of my favorite
cities caroline series it currently only
has one episode and I think he's pretty
much abandoned the series for what I've
heard our performance issues but I'm not
entirely sure in any case it's an
amazingly well done detailed recreation
of certain areas of Rotterdam so far but
- to an extent in which it is nearly
impossible to do the entire city let
alone practically possible it's just too
much of a task at that point so this
will stay and it's very not so super
detailed level and I'm probably not
going to add that much detail to the
city but what I do want to do is finish
up all of these suburbs finish up these
surrounding areas maybe even get to that
ski resort area with the TV tower as
well we'll see what kind of stuff we can
get into
but in any case bring this series to a
closure which i think is more fitting
than the stream has been done the goal
has been acheived let's leave it at here
and not do anything with this and
obviously i think at the end of this
series i should also just release the
map of the city as well now
interestingly somebody else has been
starting to do a recreation of Oslo
including the myth mayhem of the the
television tower which I can honestly
not pronounce I can try my best that
most of the Norwegian words but that is
that one is just too crazy but you
probably know which one I'm talking
about in any case that is probably bound
to be a recreation with a lot more time
and passion put into it eventually so
I'm looking forward to see that one but
for this one I'm just trying to keep
this as feasible as possible not make
the ambition too high just to make sure
that I can finish this project at all
and see this being put out not to
mention that it's somewhat playable and
not ending up as a super laggy
overly detailed but performance wise
horrible creation of amazing backyard
nests so it's not going to quite be that
sort of thing what this will be though
is a lot of time lapses once again with
a copying of the overlay and adding
zones in certain districts but not so
much changing stuff in terms of what I'm
doing I do have to say that I left out a
lot of footage there's a bunch of stuff
that I did after this time lapse which I
didn't record so there's definitely some
stuff that I'm leaving out but still
there are just hours upon hours of
copying an overlay and just toning and
just these two activities of placing
roads and placing zones exclusively
without anything else which honestly can
get really boring not just for me to do
but in time lapses as well and I'm not
saying this in a way of you know I'm
gonna leave this out and that won't be
part of the series because that's
honestly almost all that I'm doing here
just a fair warning to you that this is
not going to be that interesting and if
you want to watch this or listen to my
commentary then by all means go ahead be
my guest but I just feel like it's very
fair to say a warning what kind of
contents these videos are even if I've
already done that a little bit in the
past I think the okarian area and the
city center area were the two episodes
which are most interesting and most
varied in to in terms of content but the
rest of the city being less detailed and
being you know suburbs there is no way
around the idea that this is going to be
a little bit boring and a bit repetitive
in terms of what I'm doing which is
interesting because this was also
something that I was praised for a
little bit I didn't see so many comments
but somebody did message me on Steam I
forgot who it was but if you're
listening then thanks for that message
but somebody messaged me on Steam
praising me that for the fact that I was
actually building all of these suburbs
because what's interesting is that
you'll find a lot of YouTube series of
this game tend to have a
disproportionate amount of suburbs to
city centre honestly most cities in the
real world are a very small center area
and then you've got all of the rest of
the city kind of sprawling from the
middle of that and most cities aren't as
bad at this as Los Angeles or Phoenix
but there are still you know way more
cities with a lot of suburbs and very
little city center than there are actual
dense cities the entire way around so a
lot of cities and city skylines end up
going for maybe 50% suburbs and 50% city
center which is very skewed because
normally your city center is just kind
of one dense area in a huge field of
suburbs and creating all those suburbs
just is a bit too boring I suppose for
most - the skyline series or players as
well but yeah this series is a little
bit unique
I suppose in that fact and that most of
the city is going to be all of the
suburbs which I guess that's
something that I could be praised for
but then again I'm not entirely sure
because it's just part of Oslo and I'm
trying to recreate as large a part of
the urban agglomeration of Oslo as I can
and urban agglomerations are just mostly
suburbs in nature and I think it's
perfectly understandable why most
YouTube series end up maybe just
building a few suburbs but still
focusing on the city centre because in
the end that's what's most interesting
not to mention that these low-density
sprawled out areas are also kind of a
thing of the past and something that
were partly getting rid of at the moment
consider the eyehole idea of what
inspired this whole build one inspired
the livestream that this was made for
the fact that oaken is a very modernist
kind of part of the city with a very
sprawled out and car centric approach
which has to be redone into a modern
more livable city but yeah there's not
much more of a conversation to be had
about that I suppose it's quite obvious
at this point that generally densifying
is a little bit better than urban sprawl
and there are some things that we should
do to combat urban sprawl in fact more
or less my Ammar City city is kind of
about that even if it's in a very
unusual setting it packs a very similar
idea that's definitely been a little bit
of a theme on this channel when it comes
to City skylines I think now back to the
practical issues I suppose the city that
I'm building here one of the horrible
things that kept happening is all of
these icons popping up and when I was
talking with the guys who asked me to do
this I kept giving ideas on how many
fire stations or police stations could
be placed even if there were modern
assets with extreme stats to combat
getting all of these icons and getting
all of these problems in the city but in
the end nothing really worked and even
getting a disproportionate amount of
fire
stations etc kind of didn't exactly help
in the end scenes I think the game is
just really skewed toward gameplay in
the end the game is meant as a
simulation game and not an actual
simulation so it required too many
service buildings to actually work in
any realistic sense so I just ended up
getting the no problem smarter and I
think I didn't quite use that yet in
this episode and not entirely sure but
yeah yeah looks that way definitely but
eventually I just ended up getting me no
problems mod and removing the issues
with electricity and water that way and
even if it seems like a little bit of
cheap shortcuts yeah you certainly might
try to do it without I think if you're
doing any kind of recreation or
a well somewhat realistic city on this
kind of scale especially if you're
building everything in one go as I am
and not going for the organic approach
in game then I think something like the
no problems mod is pretty much
inevitable it's really hard to get
around those in-game issues and in
hindsight that was really one of my main
oversights thinking that just placing a
large amounts of fire stations police
stations garbage collections etc for the
game or for real life just to help the
game kind of work with everything that
was just way too ambitious it doesn't
really work in the end for example Oslo
only has two garbage sites and there is
no way that you could have a 600,000
city or people city in city skylines and
only have two places to collect your
garbage there there's no way that that's
going to work there's issues with the
garbage trucks as well as capacity of
the garbage things in here and I think
it's totally fair considering that this
is a game and you want to make things
fun and in the end at a gameplay aspect
but it's nowhere near realistic think
you'd need way too many services in this
game for any realistic city and there
was another struggle
well which became especially apparent
after this episode because at this point
I've been doing a lot of what I'm doing
in past mode just because that helps the
frame rate a lot and I prefer working
with a slightly better frame rate even
if that is 20 FPS compared to 10 FPS 20
fps is honestly not that bad in a
creative game or a building type of game
we don't really need to control a
character or anything but a huge problem
with working in pulsed mode as I came to
realize is that when I built almost half
of the city well more perhaps even or in
a single go and most of its by zoning
there is a certain point where you go
from paused to unpassed mode and the
game has to actually work out all those
different zones creating buildings
creating people for the city to inhabit
the city and creating all kinds of
commercial and office zones for the
people to work it's so much processing
power that you need for that kind of
thing that the game just went to
standstill it's not that the frame rates
started getting worse but the whole
problem that I've had of the time in the
game going super slowly became an
absolute monstrous sort of slow motion
where even if you put the game up to
three times as fast the days would still
move by extremely slowly you could see
the car is kind of creeping over the
roads and it takes a lot of time to
actually make all those zones grow so
I'm sort of considering at some point
here just leaving my computer on with
the city running trying to see if I can
get it to run as quickly as possible and
then just leave the computer for a few
hours trying to process all the people
entering the city in any case owning
everything at the same time in massive
areas of land is something that this
game can't really handle and it's a bit
of a processor thing as well it drives
on your CPU so if you do have a monster
NSA or NASA computer I guess an essay
goes as well you might be able to do
that sort of thing
but there is no way that
let the game process all of that stuff
on my computer quickly enough so at the
moment while I'm speaking I still kind
of have a city with a huge road layouts
and all kinds of amazingly laid out
zones which are as accurate as possible
to real life and yet the game can't
really build anything on them because
that would take way too much processing
power so yeah there's something to keep
in mind as well if you do do a
recreation and you're doing it as
quickly as possible it might be possible
that you're doing the recreation quicker
then the game can handle and kind of run
too far ahead it's okay though
eventually it should be all figured out
it's just gonna take some headaches to
get that all to work right but hey what
city skylines without a few headaches
err in there in other news by the way
because the boring time lapse continues
and this was a bit of a breakthrough for
me personally at least I've done a lot
of planet coaster and roller coaster
[ __ ] meetups so far but I've never done
a city skylines Meetup and last weekend
what sort of weekend actually I was
weekend because it was Easter and it
wasn't Monday there was my first city
skylines made up and it was with freedom
920 Sharon Tim the terrible and geometry
you might know them because they're all
more or less asset creators and I
haven't done much in the way of I said
creating but I guess I was there anyway
but yeah that was really cool bunch of
Dutch guys in an Australian dude we went
to do draft and discovered the city and
started talking about urban planning and
[ __ ] on the urban planning in the
city and hating on 60s modernism you
know the usual kind of stuff but yeah
that was really awesome so if any of you
guys are watching right now then thanks
that was really cool and it really
reminded me personally because I also
met up with flux trends in Los Angeles
which was about three weeks ago and that
as well was definitely awesome spent
some good time walking around the city
and exploring it in a way that I feel
like at this point is very typical for
city skylines players lots of
checking out all the buildings and
recognizing assets even from the game
which is really cool and on the other
hand also maybe a little bit
embarrassing and just kind of talking
about the whole urban fabric of the city
which is super nerdy topics but in
general I think it's pretty awesome to
do some city tours with actual city
planning nerds so that was really fun so
now I guess you kind of know a little
bit more about what goes on in my
personal life otherwise as well I
recently had a horrible train problem
issue in how aware of course the Dutch
railways had horrible delays and ended
up just kind of walking through the city
which is honestly a pretty good way to
spend your time where you're stuck in a
train station instead of standing on the
train station and just checking your
phone or something in any case that is
just about it for this video so thank
you guys for watching and I hope to see
you in the next video in which will
tackle some more amazing suburbs and
hopefully I have a little bit more to
tell about the projects as well
especially since I've still been looking
for videos of it and haven't seen any so
far so I'll keep you guys updated about
that as well bye bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you